ce château présente la gloire de celui
qu'on appellera longtemps le plus grand
roi du monde
vous avez sans doute reconnu sa voix
france miniature accueille cette année
un monument de la télévision stéphane
bern
l'animateur enregistré des commentaires
audio sur 12 sites historiques français
avec au programme des anecdotes une
vraie passion pour monsieur le
patrimoine sur un site à elancourt vous
avez un ensemble tous les joyaux de la
france et je trouve que c'est une mise
en valeur du patrimoine pour les
générations qui viennent et on est dans
le lent vie de transmettre aux jeunes
générations
je me dis mais si ça peut éveiller le
goût de des visiteurs et leur donner
envie d'aller voir en vrai sur place
j'aurai réussi mon pari
via des bornes interactives stéphane
bern propose un tour de france du
château de chambord en passant par
l'hôtel des invalides à paris
avec ce partenariat france miniature
espère booster sa fréquentation et vise
le chiffre de 200 mille visiteurs sur
cette saison 2018
stéphane bern est un moteur je pense que
cela peut intéresser nombre de visiteurs
et puis surtout ça permet d'ouvrir la
culture et l'histoire à des nouveaux
visiteurs et d'apporter à
par un nouveau billet un nouveau canal
et de séduire d'autres types de
populations je pense aux enfants
notamment qui le suivent à la télévision
et qui pourront le retrouver sur le par
la voix de stéphane bern sera à
découvrir dès le samedi 14 avril à
france miniature les guerres de religion